[Music]
close them like before Christmas and a
good guy in red was hunting down bad
guys why the red suit well that's so bad
guys can't see me bleed this guy's got
the right idea he wore the brown pants
let's recap they messed with his face
and kidnapped his girl is not used to be
in the hero
nobody's getting hurt Merry Christmas
dr. freda new trailer online tomorrow
hey youtubers is Charlie happy Christmas
the new Deadpool footage this is just
like a little bit of what's going to be
in the full trailer tomorrow and we
actually get to hear the new Colossus
speak so I'm gonna play that clip really
quick too and very turned on right now
there was just like two different
versions of this exact same teaser
trailer so I don't want I don't want to
play the whole thing twice but you can
see what they've done with the Colossus
they've done the Game of Thrones
Mountain thing if you don't watch Game
of Thrones there's a character named the
mountain he's been recast three times in
four seasons where the most recent
iteration is involved in a lot of
close-up battles and they want him to
see way way larger so like the most
recent actors they've cast it's just
like massive just like the biggest human
being you've ever seen so they've done
the same thing with Colossus in his
Deadpool movie they've used a little bit
of CG to to make them even bigger but
the interesting thing about the teaser
is is that it kind of tells us the story
of the movie pretty close to the comic
book origins of Deadpool's fight with
Ajax but not you know they just make
like a few minor changes like this is
happening in present day so this is not
occurring in real time with x-men
apocalypse even though it is connected
to the x-men universe
negasonic teenage warhead there is part
of Emma Frost class of telepaths she's
used more of like a Precog so like she
gets visions of terrible things
happening in the future so that's
probably why she's here but originally
in the comics when Deadpool is going
through the variant of the Weapon X
program with doctor Killebrew he
develops his rivalry with Ajax ends up
torching the whole place because like
Wolverine did when he was in the Weapon
X program but before that happened Ajax
in order to punish Deadpool had been
killing all of his friends inside the
program
so Deadpool swore revenge took the name
Deadpool and then eventually tried to
track down a killer Ajax but before that
happened
Ajax like survived the big destruction
of the Weapon X program and went around
trying to kill all the other people
associated with Weapon X you're a
fighter we can give you abilities most
men only dream
make you a superhero will you just
promise you'll do right by me so I can
do right by someone else and please
don't make the supersuit green or
animated one thing that never survives
this place it's a sense of human I will
see about that posh spice oh come on you
know leave me all alone here with less
angry Rosie O'Donnell so it seems like
in this movie
Ajax tracks down copycat Deadpool his
girlfriend from before he became
Deadpool trying to use her to get a
Deadpool
so Ajax is seeming like the biggest film
of the movie at least right now
sometimes there's always the guy behind
the guy but I think they wanted this
Deadpool movie to feel like a standalone
if they didn't ever end up making any
others as part of the supposed final
kill they end up dousing Ajax and
gasoline while Deadpool is killing him
but of course it's the comic books so no
one ever truly dies so you end up seeing
Ajax like throughout Deadpool's history
deadpool hallucinates him every once in
a while so he's never truly gone but
here's the details on the trailer
tomorrow in case you don't want gspn or
you don't watch basketball don't worry
I'm totally gonna post the trailer when
it comes but it's probably gonna be
around like 1:00 p.m. Pacific time so
it's basically like halftime wherever
the NBA game is playing wherever you're
at and I know everyone's going crazy
because Hugh Jackman posted this
Wolverine teaser with Deadpool on it on
his Facebook page like his giant
Facebook page so I do think that
Wolverine is going to have some minor
involvement with the movie you know very
brief cameo maybe just explain the
connection with the first class
franchise so you have like Bryan
Singer's first class franchise that's
going on right now there x-men
apocalypse is coming out really soon but
that takes place during the 80s this
movie is connected to that universe but
it's taking place much closer to
present-day
so we're seeing all this stuff happened
to Deadpool all that big fight with
apocalypse has already happened so I'm
curious to see if the movie addresses
that at all because then I know Fox
wants the same type of synergy between
its movies that Marvel has the new
trailer coming tomorrow so be sure to
subscribe to get it I've already done a
bunch of Deadpool Christmas video so
like I will put like a link at the end
of the video actually in fact you know
in case you haven't seen any of those
Deadpool videos they've done a bunch of
like funny moments and Bryan Reynolds
you know doing just like funny promo
footage you can click here for all that
stuff and you can click here for the new
flash season 2 trailer with killer frost
like full-blown killer frost and the
reverse flash he is coming back thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you
tonight
you